Yeah,
this does my reproduction
piece
from the conceptual level between group
identification,
whatever stage of moral
coming after it,
and the idea here is think of this
initial stage is childhood.
It goes a horse presumptions of did
undergo a horse disintegration
adolescence,
I suppose mostly for biological reasons,
which is to say that
cause a physiological changes,
the environment to which someone has to
adapt changes dramatically.
And adolescents,
the world isn't the same place,
so whoever you were as a child has to
undergo mark revision in order for you
to become an adult.
But the problem is that half the age of
14 or so,
you're not really ready to become an
adult,
so to speak,
whatever that means and the intermediary
intermediary process,
there's trying to draw
between that and
the notion of an apprenticeship
and then the final stages.
Another accomplished by means of another
as a consequence of more than all this
information in all this information and
hits this time would be the fact that
that there are more than that.
There was more than one group.
I guess that might be the simplest way
to describe it.
If you're a traditional Jew for example,
that's not such a problem unless you
have to share a territory with
traditional Christian,
in which case the fact that group
identification,
the mere fact that then becomes a form
of anomalous information that requires a
solution.
The solution can be obliterate your
enemy,
which is I think,
denial of anomalous information because
the problem with obliterating your enemy
is that you're making the presupposition
that all of the things that we had to
offer you were worthless and I think
that's probably an error of the mid size
everything is that just because you get
rid of someone,
you tend not to get rid of the ideas
that they represent.
Right.
Those ideas pop up again,
sometimes in the form of schismatic
movements within your own culture.
If the culture,
if an enemy culture is being successful,
that sort of indicates that it's come up
with ideas that are good and the chances
are that you're not going to get rid of
those ideas if you get rid of those
people.
So it's a pretty,
it's a kind of a temporary solution.
Vast.
It might also be really
counterproductive in the long run
because the things that your enemy knows
might be things that you need to know,
but maybe not right now.
It's always possible to that they know
some things you don't.
So I think that there's,
I mean ways,
I guess what I'm trying to say in the
sense,
because I think it isn't an analogy on
the sociopolitical level between the
repression of enemies groups and the
process of repression of anomalous
information at the level of the
individual.
So
that's a,
that's an analogy that I'll keep much
more often than the last part of this
course.
Well,
the question is where do you go from
group identification?
And the answer to that seems to be what
the next stage,
or at least an insulary or auxiliary
stage,
is to know that there's a process that
characterize as the construction of
groups themselves,
which is,
I think if you think your group is
valuable,
it's very difficult to make the claim
that the process that made the group
isn't more valuable.
You see you're sort of,
you're sort of trapped by that precept
position right off,
right off the bat species.
If your group's valuable,
the process that created it is more
valuable.
I think that's,
that's a necessarily logical conclusion.
No,
I told you,
I don't know if I told you this story
before,
but there's was an interesting example
of this sort of argument in the New
Testament which I actually quote later
in this [inaudible] where the Pharisees
are attempting to trap Christ into
staying something heretical so that they
can totally prisoner killed him and he
says to one of the,
essentially you're the sort of person
who would have killed the prophets who
constructed the group that you
mentioned,
which was really
maximally effective installed and also
absolutely true.
Now contacting the way,
I don't remember which book that at the
moment,
I kind of read that as the comment that
more or less sealed his fate section
essentially credible in salt uses a
variant of that as well,
which I don't remember
it.
Stay in here,
which is your group identification.
You forfeit this process.
And the problem is is that the process
that constructed the group is more
valuable that the growth,
so if you identify with your group as an
authoritarian structure,
then you necessarily sever your
connection with the process that the
group and that constitutes a form of
spiritual death.
So in terms of constructing the
appropriate hierarchy of values,
when you realize that there's something
wrong with the answer of group
identification to the processes of life
are to the questions of life,
the next stage is to recognize that
there is the possibility of identifying
with the process.
That's what this diagram is trying to
represent.
I would say in primitive primitive cells
first new aren't confined.
This position is the sharman stay going
through their own individual process of
initiation.
It isn't necessarily the group foster,
and I was thinking about that this
morning.
It's also the case that the show,
and this is interesting showman's for
example,
the Siberians have a working vocabulary
that's many times greater than that of
their compatriots who aren't shauna
because they're the repository of the
entire world tradition of the tribe.
And which means they have the bill of
rights because they're not,
they're not.
They don't.
So it is the case that the showman is
not only someone who's an individual in
the true sense of the word being outside
of the group,
although necessary part of it.
He's also the master of the group to a
much greater degree than any of the
people who were normally identified with
it.
Well that's a good lesson because what
it says is 50 get here,
you really have to be in there,
which is something you pointed out last
week that you don't get like we think,
I think we think in the west,
and this is one of the pathologies of
primitive self help psychology that you
can get from here to here.
This is used to be vaguely construed
without without this.
And we have,
of course,
we love any of these intermediary
stages.
That's a big mistake
because this is literally somewhere
beyond this and that means it has to be
everything decision plus something else.
So okay,
so you said in the class that we can
pass on wisdom regenerations right.
We think we passed on through conscious
of attraction or whatever,
you know,
through all lot of different processes.
So it seems that if it can be passed
through,
uh,
through the spoken word at three
stories,
it seems like people don't necessarily
have to go through chaos to advance to
another identity.
If they,
if this stuff can be passed on,
we'll go with it.
Well,
the fact that the information is there,
it doesn't necessarily,
as you were pointing out,
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're
in contact with him is traumatic.
Okay,
hang on.
I have another diagram.
We'll address that problem.
That's again,
depends on the level at which the
anomalous or current school curves
basically.
And there are more and less traumatic
lemons.
I mean,
I tried to tell you a little bit about
that before,
the notion that,
you know,
if you're going somewhere and one of
your ways of getting there as blocked
will,
that constitutes in the nautilus
occurrence.
But if you're going somewhere and then
the place itself disappears,
that's a completely different class of
the dance and events in the first class.
While they're all listening to this.
And the second class are no homeless,
but obviously having to switch plans is
nowhere near as traumatic as having to
switch ideals.
Right?
So you might think about as a
qualitative difference,
that's when you go up.
It's not that simple.
And we'll take a look at most a tree
like the tree to cut it,
right.
It's very much,
it's very much like like,
like like the tree.
Okay,
so this is what we were discussing last
week.
No,
it's obvious that people can tolerate a
certain amount of normal information
that's equally obvious.
Then there were severities of anomalies,
so to speak,
that people construe as intolerable.
And one of the things that we need to do
is to construct a conceptual model.
It will help us to determine how under
what circumstances and normally is how
to determine the relative,
our effect and intensity of an anomalous
occurrence,
I guess.
Because obviously some forms of normally
they're trivial in some are major and it
would be good to figure out under what
circumstances they are trivial and maybe
what circumstances their major,
what are the things I want you to keep
it in the back of your mind because,
and this is really useful even for those
of you that are interested in
psychopathology,
say on a scientific level here.
Here's why.
You know,
if you develop a phobia,
the theory for the development of the
phobia is exposure to the thing that
caused the phobia.
That's right.
The most safe for you're afraid of mice.
So,
uh,
but the problem with that theory is that
the cure is exposure to has been very
difficult in the behavioral literature
to figure out why exposing yourself to
the same thing that causes your problem.
Curiously,
when it was exposure to that thing to
begin with,
the doors of the problem.
This is a very difficult problem.
But you know,
there's two types of [inaudible],
two basic types and one hero is where
are you accidentally and counted them
knowing and then you die.
And none of your myth is where you come
in voluntarily and then you live.
And that's the difference between the
kind of exposures that creates mythology
and the kind of exposure that creates
healing.
Because if you're a behavior therapist
for example,
what you do is you set up the
circumstances so that the person you're
trying to treat voluntarily encounters
counters the anonymous experience.
So basically you cast them,
you're doing playing her own ritual.
And in the ritual you're casting the
movie of the rule of the hero who's
willing to encounter the enormous
information voluntarily.
And this isn't just a trait rereading of
psychopathological literature and
exposure.
We know we that if you take someone
who's afraid of an elevator into it,
the elevator,
and they avoid,
because people will do that.
So even if you get them in the owner,
they'll not look at it if you can,
if you can convince them to take the
risk of really exposing themselves to
the thing that they're afraid of,
which basically means,
obviously means to explore it and to
construct a new behavioral pattern as a
consequences.
But then they get better.
If you're agoraphobic and you're afraid
of a mall and you go to the mall and
your symptoms come up and you run away,
and that makes your problems worse,
not better.
If you go to the mall and your symptoms
come up and you stay there as a
consequence of your own choice,
your symptoms,
I'll hit a plateau of like an intense
plot help.
It'll be good.
It'll deteriorate over time.
And that cures you so well,
Mrs Mrs and Wesson for again,
I want to point out Freud's eat
improvement.
That's a failed hero myth because need
to put some counters.
He sleeps with his mother in that
screening and assessment,
that's accidental and he blinds himself
as a consequence.
So Friday.
And I would say that you,
that it's reasonable to make claim that
Freudian psychology is a form of
religion.
It's based on a failed hero myth,
which is as opposed to most religions
that have lasted for the time material
always based on successful here are
immense because
successful here wasn't means that
application,
if you don't follow that pattern,
and I'll say it again so it's not
successful then in the end,
the eatable mint now Friday and well I
don't know what,
I don't know what necessary conclusions
you can draw from the fact that Freud
kicked the deployment and it's a fail
hero myth.
No,
I don't think so.
I don't know.
I don't think so because like Freud
thought that the homeowner was the
actual mother,
but that's often the case for someone
who is severity neurotic with let's say
the top.
Let's say that when you Reutemann
started from,
from observation and reason and then
using that analogy.
Yeah,
he didn't start with,
he didn't start with the integral mix
men.
No,
he started playing out there on the
implications lives and then just saw in
the story,
but he still said and then saw the,
the mythical stories that seem to map
onto the experiences of the patients
that he saw.
But he did say,
me and me,
if that's the central problem of life,
that's the central problem.
Like,
and it's universal for Freud,
every culture in every culture,
that's the central problem.
Now that's been criticized on
anthropological grounds,
which aren't really relevant here,
but I still think that it's more than
just
more than just a historical fluke,
the things or manage themselves that
way.
Because he also have to realize that
when Freud and Jung Split,
the reason that they split,
for example,
it was on the question of whether or not
religion survey and useful function now
on Friday taking a myth.
Well that was a myth of failure in a
sense and said,
well that's,
you know,
that goes to the central problem to that
application.
So it wasn't a premarital sexual aspect
of that.
Yeah,
it was.
But see the thing about mythologies that
it represent sexual union with the
mother asked the incest motif and Freud
thought of that as something literal.
He thought,
as Freud tended to do,
he offered a literal translation of
something that was involved.
He said that's actually what it referred
to a,
he was using it as an analogy that he
was taking a more concrete level,
which is always good in his approach
would be to take the,
like you said,
to start with the fuel said sectionality
and mythology with symbol.
Freud said symbolism and mythology
resection,
right.
Said that
symbolism and mythology was sexual and
viewing said that sexual symbolism and
mythology,
the sexualities mythology,
the symbol
that floyd was tackling sexual assaulted
not.
Well,
yeah.
Again though,
that's not precisely true because it
was,
it was for Freud in the Victorian
patients that he encountered,
it was,
sexuality was problematic because it was
contaminated with a no,
it wasn't problematic because of his
sexuality.
It was problematic because it was
unexplored territory and unexplored
territory for the Victorian neurotics
half of the primary and sexual in
origin.
So he saw a sexuality as the presenting
problem,
but it wasn't.
It was unexplored territory if it was
any problem in the guise of sexual
dysfunction.
I explored territory in the consulting
where it comes in all sorts of forums
and it might come in the form of an
unresolved relationship with your mother
who is a form of God,
so to speak when you're a child and you
can say that for the struggling neurotic
saying that this is a person who has a
dependent personality disorder.
There is struggle with the parental
situation is an analog of the process of
adaptation in the world.
So the parents,
when you're 25 30 your parents should no
longer be parents.
They should be other.
They should be other people who you've
had an intense relationship with,
but who are other people?
Your parents should be someone else.
By that point,
if your parents are still your parents,
then the battle you should be playing
out in the world,
it's still being played out for you and
your family and Freud's neurotic
patients were like that.
They never got,
they never made it.
They never made it of here.
He never made it to here much less to
here.
You know,
they were still struggling with,
well,
how,
how do I deal with the childhood
environment?
The thing is that,
uh,
the
adaptation to what we're talking about
here is as it certainly seems to be
appraised and our most fundamental
biological systems than any,
any concept,
any story that you're used to talking
about it.
Because on some level,
right to talking about the same thing.
So in that sense,
of course they were talking about the
same thing they're talking about the
most basic,
right?
Right.
That's,
that's it.
Good.
That's a good comment.
I mean that's,
that is one of the characteristics of
stories that Freud cold calls
the fact that his story is meaningful on
multiple levels simultaneously.
Now that's a good,
that's a perfectly good introduction to
the next diagram here.
Okay.
You remember though,
the old diagram,
you'll see the analogies here.
You know which one I talked?
All right.
Okay.
So before what we had,
we were a bunch of arrows here,
right?
This being the ends and these being the
means to get there.
But that's not a sufficient way of
looking at the problem and since you
already have mastered that way of
looking at it,
so we'll introduce more difficult level
and that level is that all the ways of
getting to an Anne are also structures
that are like the whole structure,
which is to say that when you're doing
anything,
when you engaged in any activity,
you're engaged in a whole nested
hierarchy of goal directed behavior and
the NASA thing goes all the way down to
the lowest level of analysis and all the
way up to so a kind of Maine,
how do you construe this while you're
sitting in this class and you have a
certain year and trying to attain
certain goals in,
in just this lecture and this lectures
nasty in this class and this class is
nested in your educational curriculum
and your educational curriculum is
nested in your,
in your career goals and your career
goals of nested in your culture and your
culture is to then,
well then it gets a little bit more
difficult.
What's your culture has to,
well,
I would say it's nested in religious
presuppositions.
What do they nested parts,
an estimate,
philosophical presuppositions.
Then in religious presuppositions,
then in behavioral place up positions
and so on.
Knows how far and also down how far and
even within the domain of the class,
the single lecture while you're doing
anything in particular that's a subgoal
tenacity inside of the class like you're
taking notes because this point has
relevance at different levels of
analysis.
There's all sorts of procedures that you
undertaking as the class continues
anyways.
Now there's different ways of thinking.
This is vague by the way.
This is going to be a vague lecture
because some of the things that I'm
talking about,
you talking with you about today,
I'm trying to figure out because there
was some errors in my original
presuppositions.
I'm trying to clear them up so if you
have any comments that you think are
particularly insightful,
I'd be more than happy to hear them say
you can think of this as a corporate
structure to the whole corporations
going off to do something and these
would be vice presidents sort of
equivalent status and then each vice
president would occupy a domain.
He has underlings and they have their
particular story to,
to act out in the domain of the
corporation and they govern some other
people and so on and so forth,
all the way down to the bottom level of
analysis.
And even a thing like the corporation.
If you think of this as a corporation or
any other,
any other structure for that matter.
Again,
corporations are nested inside of
political structure that's nested inside
it philosophical structure.
That's why people pay.
Businessmen are generally advocates,
at least at least explicitly of the free
market because their whole story only
maintains its validity within the
context of a whole network of
philosophical presuppositions.
Right?
So,
and that's the case at every single
level of analysis.
You know,
I guess part of what we're interested in
is like what's at the highest level of
analysis,
what's out there at the edge.
I just wanted to ask you if you would
point out where you making corrections
as we go along.
If one,
when you said you were going to make,
you said this would be a little vague
because there's some mechanism
corrections and measured and there's
only,
yeah.
Well,
this is slightly different than what
we're basically did it with chapter four
here.
The idea is not necessarily different,
but diagrams.
No,
it's still [inaudible] I'm still in the
same ballpark.
I'm just trying to,
this is still the same.
If there was any
breast
story,
behavioral story are at odds and then
you're neurotic.
No,
I mean that,
I mean,
yes,
it has to be hierarchical and all this
has to be subjugated to ask the
question,
what does it have to be subjugated to?
That's why I put this,
this diagram up.
Well look,
there's going to be lots of situations
where you can have a story,
a story B and they're going along in
parallel and there's no problem
whatsoever.
Just like there are lots of cases where
culture,
Asian culture be occupied in the same
territory more or less,
no problem.
But then now and then a historical event
and that event points out those areas
where those two parallel stories
actually conflict.
So look,
for a most of us,
most of us Westerners so to speak,
are the educated population.
There is a conflict for us,
I think between how we act and our moral
presuppositions and how we conceive of
the universe.
From the scientific perspective,
it's a big conflict.
Well,
most of the time it doesn't make any
difference,
but now and then it makes a big
difference.
And in the,
when we only,
when you say that someone's
psychologically integrated or when you
say someone,
when you see someone who has an
impeccable character,
that might mean I'm looking at it.
What you see is the fact that all their
stories take one story because they're
not working at cross purposes.
So you can be offering different
stories.
Well,
superstructure,
if you're an integrated,
you have a superstructure
that I think is relatively explicit to
which all your other brands are made
subject,
which is the credit.
And then the question is what
constitutes the king?
You could look at this at Lawrence of
different levels of analysis.
Okay.
You say,
well,
all your different motivational
subsystems have to operate in harmony,
right?
So each of them has to take all of the
others into account.
The vice presidents.
Well,
that might be one way of looking at it.
Sure.
I mean there's,
I was thinking more in intro psyche and
speaking.
You have to eat,
you have to sleep,
you need social contact,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
There's all these basic preconditions
for your existence that have to be mad,
all of those,
and you have specialized biological
subsystems that are responsible for
ensuring that one of those particular
needs is math and the way those systems
ensure that is by,
I think by gripping your fantasy when
something within you is out of kilter.
So for example,
if you're in this class,
you have need for five hours while I'm
talking intrusive thoughts about what
you might need afterwards are going to
pop into the theater of your mind
because that's the subsystem that's
responsible for maintaining your caloric
intake is not being satisfied by your
current state of goal directed activity.
Your job to adapt is to organize all
those motivational subsystems into a
unit such that none of them conflict and
so that all of the more towards the same
man so that all of them get what they
need.
Well.
Also paying attention to the fact that
every other one gets what it means.
Now,
the same thing exactly can be said about
your relationships with other people,
because you could say just as you have
to take all of your needs into account,
you're operating in a social environment
and to take all your needs into account
also means to take into account the
needs of everyone that you come into
contact with.
So it's also the,
it's,
it is the case.
Even that when you're trying to modulate
the environment so that you get what you
have to get a lot of the environment
that you're modulating his other people.
So there's a nice amorphism between the
way you construct your internal
hierarchy and the way that the social
hierarchy round,
he was constructed,
unnecessary isomorphism networks all the
way up.
Now,
the Mesopotamians,
they asked,
they asked the question,
who should be king?
And on the mythical level,
that means who should determine
destinies.
And what that means is how it should
behave.
They're operating under what ages and
the Enuma Elish,
which is their creation story,
says all gods should be subordinate to
Martech.
Martech,
the garden goes up to the unknown,
creates the world,
and that's what this diagram is about,
right?
That's your group identification.
So that's a provision,
lance to the problem with that
adaptation question is though,
what should everything be subordinate to
including your group?
I think medication,
which is your particular solution to
your motivation problems on that's
everything should be subordinate to the
process that generates new inflammation
out of the encounter with them and
updates known territory.
That's okay.
So then to,
to get right back to your question,
all your stories should be arranged in a
hierarchy such that the highest story,
his allegiance with the process that
engages in creative contact with the
unknown and to the degree that that's
not the case,
then you've deviated from the path.
So for example,
there's another new testaments during
their crisis,
it's more theirs.
He's driving on a cart with the rich man
and rich man says,
what do I have to do to get into heaven
and crisis?
We have to sell everything you own.
And all the disciples that are just
flabbergasted by this,
you know,
they don't like this.
I said,
well,
if that's the case,
there's no hope.
No one's going to do that.
And then of course,
as well as easier for account and go
through the avenue in which men and
they're having now the reason for that,
it has nothing to do with money.
It has nothing to do with money.
It has to do with the relative
importance of goals.
He says,
if,
because this young guy is so preoccupied
with this wealth and maintaining it,
which is this,
but he won't risk this to do this,
and so all that that story is pointing
out is that if you want this and you
won't risk this to do this,
then you don't get this,
which is what you really want.
Even though you don't know it's your
money is just a proxy for that.
It's false security.
There's a copy machine right outside the
door for one second.
Okay.
I think we could write notes on it.
Would you consider that?
Yes,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
Look,
one of the things that need cheap ass,
late 18 hundreds was our,
their neurosis of health.
And by that he meant can you be properly
adopted to pathological circumstance of
[inaudible]?
Yes.
It's like when you say crime of
obedience,
what you say is adherence to this and
the sacrifice of this.
That's why most people are a little bit
before.
Well,
it's also looked like it was like,
you know,
one of the things that the 20th century
is having struggle with is the notion of
crimes against humanity.
It's right because the Nazi would say
and and accurately would say,
look,
I'm a trivial individual.
I'm just doing my job.
I was following orders that move down
the hierarchy.
It wasn't my responsibility.
No.
Normally,
not only was it not my responsibility,
but I wasn't doing what I should have
done.
And you can say,
well,
those people were just rationalizing
their behavior.
But the point is,
is that they're making a valid
statement.
But the Nuremberg trial says,
look,
for reasons we don't understand,
which is to say for for reasons we can't
make explicit,
there are certain rules you can break
even if you're,
even if you're morally operate from this
perspective,
which is to say there's certain rbc you
can't fall.
I think that's tough,
isn't it?
Because if you're a soldier in the war
time and your commander say three or
four levels of hierarchy up says,
you know,
shoot these villagers and you don't
shoot them,
your dad.
But the number of Charles says,
tough luck.
Basically there are,
um,
there are certain orders you can't fall.
And then the question is,
well,
what does that mean?
There are certain orders you can fall.
Well,
it means that there's something outside
of what you can define explicitly or
what your culture is defined explicitly
or it doesn't mean anything.
I would say,
well,
the crime against humanity,
this is the definition.
You do what this says instead of what
this says.
And that's the definition.
Perhaps it just means that to,
you
realize,
okay,
in the in the tire,
which would be the person who gave you
the order?
Yeah.
In the first one it tells you that you
shouldn't well enough.
They don't know why.
Fair enough.
Although I like I,
I think that,
I do think that the Nuremberg trials
were,
I don't think that it's reasonable to
construe them as,
as the response of one tire need to,
the excesses of enough.
I don't think so.
I think there's more to it than that.
Even though you know,
for the person who's caught in the
middle,
I mean they're in trouble or it looks
the same.
That's true.
How do you go?
Well that's the whole last half of the
course just because that's what I'm
interested in is like,
because of these isoboards isms exist.
But I mean,
the simple answer to that is that your,
your personal response to anomalous
information in a way that's not trivial
determines the course of your culture in
a way that like,
which seems complete.
That seems like a completely ridiculous
statement,
but
I still think it's true.
So
culture that's made up of people who
take the character logically negative
stairs towards it,
homeless information back.
So that's a fascist state.
That's why well thing about a fascist
state and Scott,
just the structure,
it's a,
you have to remember that our current
states,
our bodies of law,
which means they're,
they're explicit descriptions of
behavioral patterns that when put into
operation are actually embodied.
It's right there rules about how to act,
which is to say what a state is,
is this is a description of an ideal
personality.
All the laws in this state constitute
the description of an ideal personality.
Because what the law says is at least
you can't do this.
So in this it defining is what you
should be by exclusion,
right?
And all those things that you can do,
well that makes up the ideal citizen and
everyone who's the member of the same
culture is a duplicate of that ideal
citizen.
So then the question again is what's the
ideal citizen?
And someone who's bureaucratically and
client will say,
well,
the ideal citizen does exactly what the
hell you tell him to do.
And that makes everyone predictable.
But then there's this leap above that
morality which says,
well,
no,
the ideal citizen knows what to do and
what not to do according to the rules.
But when the circumstances change
or when the circumstances call for it,
then there's another morality that
supersedes the group identity on upon
which group structure is necessarily
maintain.
That's the thing that's so interesting
has been the harder you try to ensure
that these boundaries are impermeable,
the more likely you are to kill
everything that's inside here.
Just
social around the identity was the
hardest question for anyone who is,
what should I do?
That's what so is it through the goal?
Well,
yes.
That's sure.
Sure.
Look,
we do not want to ever make the mistake
of presuming that there are tremendous
advantages to staying inside here.
I mean it's,
there's no anomaly.
What?
What's the problem?
Well,
there's no interest.
I mean because if you are by definition,
if you exclude novelty,
you exclude incentive reward.
So what happens is that you get
protection at the cost of,
of all the interest in life.
Now what this alternative route says,
well,
if you do,
if you face the anomalous information,
there's enough interest generating
there,
which is enough hope so to speak,
that that in itself will provide a
barrier against all of the negative
potentialities.
They don't occur as a consequence of
doing this,
which is to say if you're willing to
take the leap outside,
there are phenomena that you will
encounter there that will protect you
from all the negative things that you've
encountered.
So here,
everything is predictable but sterile.
That's why mythology and it kingdom
ruled by a tire and everything dries up,
right?
The river's disappeared,
the trees died,
the grass dies.
Everything's dad and everything's old.
But as you just pointed out with the
Nuremberg trials,
that's not necessarily true.
You jump outside,
you're quite likely to end up dead
depending on what,
how,
on how strong the of the people who are
trying to learn bird didn't jump
outside.
No,
but I mean you,
I was referring back to the elephant is
the fascist state.
You were discussing the person,
if someone four or five levels up orders
you to kill these villagers.
Yes.
If you don't do it,
you're dead.
I mean,
and that's joe and that's jumping out.
So I have to read the second volume of
the Gulag archipelago because that
answers that question and there's no
simple answer to it.
So because let's say if you want to
start the book,
there's a chapter at the end which you
protein in the personality texted last
year called the soul and barb wire.
And this is exactly the issue that
Solzhenitsyn discusses that says when
the price for stepping outside of his
death,
then what?
Wow.
Read the book because it's the only,
it's the only book.
I know that there have been other books
written like that.
I mean he really address either,
I mean,
either you die or you or you stay in
well,
well is not,
not necessarily because the thing is the
threats for stepping outside their real,
it's like this,
this chaos might've been death.
I mean this is a real thing.
You know,
it's not just the,
it's not just a circle.
That's right.
It's fun just to see a glow in the mall
might kill.
I mean,
people get depressed and then they
should themselves,
you know,
it's like this is really dangerous and
one of the things that might have to use
might get killed.
That's why in one of the standard
features of a hero mythology is the
negative encounter with the group,
right?
Quality in the New Testament story of,
for example,
Christ is exposed to this appears all,
all who've said,
kill him.
And so that's the price for stepping
outside,
even though theoretically he's,
he's the embodiment of the process.
That revitalizes group last week you
talked a little bit about the MTA,
right?
Right.
Well,
that's what this is trying to represent.
What's the motivation for fronting that
much?
What is it
that motivates someone to step two?
Well,
I would say,
again,
it's anomalous information here full.
I see it's full of this,
but why don't characterize it
motivates a movement.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
the simple answer to that was faith.
One of the things that human said that
was useful,
the voter religious tradition and the
use of religious traditions and
psychotherapy,
isn't it?
If prior to the dawn of empirical
medicine,
um,
uh,
cultural,
medical personality,
if you were suffering from a particular
disease would tell you a story about a
god who had the same problem and your
mythical participation in the adventures
of that God would constitute and
curative ritual.
Some of these rituals are very,
very elaborate.
Now you could say that the purpose of a
religion in the sense is to provide you
with a body of images that describes how
this process works and then points out
in the sense that there's a light at the
end of the tunnel and it's like
identification with that image can sort
of provide a barrier against all the
chaos that's outside of the group.
So that's what I identification with the
central figure of a given religion.
That's what that's supposed to do.
So it's,
it's almost,
look,
here's an example,
vampire movie vampires hate crosses,
right?
There are a vampire is a symbol of the
unknown.
There's some sexual contamination there
as a general rule too,
but it's a night creature.
The Sun destroys it and you can be
protected against it by the cross is one
of the things that works in horror
stories.
And I frequent the occurrences.
This backfires after a priest and he
holds up across in,
it's glowing when he's out of there and
then the priest gets afraid and the glow
goes away and the vampire eats them.
It doesn't exactly the same notion.
Takes his bloody way.
Well it's ident well anyways,
that was the best answer.
That question I think.
Okay.
So the first thing I want to say is
that,
so you,
you call the second level up their
identity identification with the group,
right?
It's adolescence because that's out of
the license.
Now you said that even when you do,
when you try to be an individual,
you still part of a group of people who
think that they're individuals.
So I would say it would be possible to,
to think of that the top oval as
identification with a group who's,
who's,
uh,
main motivation is the process.
Yeah.
I think that's still possible.
And the second thing I want to say is,
um,
what is it?
That's a perfectly reasonable way of
looking at it.
Although it's a group composed of people
whose job is to revive my screws.
So it's not a group,
it's not a group.
It's a medic group.
[inaudible] group.
No,
no.
This is an important point because one
of the things that I brought up
yesterday or last week was there's two
types of primary philosophical question
in a Samsung scope relative.
First question is,
what is the good,
and that's a question,
but then there's a medic question,
which is what is the nature of the
process?
The provides answers to the question,
what is the good?
Now a group answers the question.
So what is the good being an arts?
What is the nature of the process that
allows you to answer the question?
What is the good,
well,
that's identification with them.
That group and [inaudible] group is the
group of all individuals whose job is to
revitalize the group.
So I think that is possible to fit in
that that,
okay,
fine,
fair enough.
The second thing I'm going to say is
that I don't think that it's possible
for everyone to attain that level.
Although I'd like to.
I don't,
what do you mean not possible?
I think that some people,
uh,
temperament wise or not.
So you say that the top level,
uh,
um,
no,
the monsters you encounter.
Exactly.
You're so right.
Right,
right,
right.
Okay.
Right.
So,
but you've said that Shamans,
you said Shamans are people in that
upper oval,
right?
I would say.
Okay.
So now the,
the Mayans and Aztecs do believe that
not everyone can be a showman.
That's true.
That only certain people with certain,
uh,
unconscious,
you know,
it's just of unconscious strength could
be one.
And so I think that it's,
you know,
some people just have a,
okay,
again,
I want to go talking and say,
well,
that's a perfectly reasonable objection
in a sense,
but it's also the case that heroism in
the sense,
so curves and different levels of
[inaudible].
Right.
So let's,
I want to show you another dining room.
Well,
we asked,
okay.
Oh,
well here,
let's do a simpler one first.
So there was this side here,
right?
That's how your plans are actually
organized and under some circumstances,
you know,
planning your plan B and they're both
more or less what this is as good as the
other.
That doesn't really work.
But it's a reasonable way of,
because almost always you do plan a
because it's better than plan b.
At least they think of it.
So we didn't,
it occupies a position that's higher up
in the hierarchy and you'll shift down
to plan B if you have to.
So that's where I've said,
well you have two alternative plans and
this would be the representation where,
well,
no,
you just,
it's only one plan.
This and ask is ultimately you can only
do one thing at a time.
That's the problem.
That's right.
That's why,
that's actually why we have interests.
Like in conflict,
I think we have one output apparatus and
a dozen input around says and only one
gets control at a time.
So that's the nature of quotes.
Like this is when a motivational system,
they say run like hell and motivation be
just to be,
to say,
well,
let's get something to eat and
motivational system C is saying,
well,
we should actually go visit our friends,
so that's conflict and there's all to
get all this record.
It's one on foot.
That's right.
That's an effective just regulation and
went up with a service.
That's true.
That's what we're hoping for.
One output that serious,
all goals fall.
All of those are valid.
That's what we're looking for.
What behavioral pattern best satisfies
all conceivable motivational goals in a
social context composed of individuals
who are doing exactly the same thing,
but that'll have to be completed over
time.
There's more,
there's more to it that works over time.
It's stable enough to maintain itself
and flexible enough to readjust.
That's the criteria for the southern
shit that's missed it in.
Yes,
temp temporality makes a big difference
because what works.
That's why authority.
Another traction for authoritarian
societies is they work but not for very
long.
They're not very good at,
don't have very good at power
transitions.
When the king dies,
all of the people that he squashed or
just squashed paypal does not make very
good kings,
sort of makes the authoritarian state
the client.
So,
okay,
now
let's look at how you actually maybe
choose between different alternatives.
Now this is,
this kind of touches on some of the
things we discussed yesterday.
If you know,
this is a,
this is an interesting question.
You fail a test and uh,
well that blows your course goal.
Let's say your core school was getting
any,
now you're going to get a seat and maybe
it has some trends,
even effects on your educational
attainment,
some even more trans effects on career.
Okay.
The Valence of the normals,
inflammation,
which is the b minus shifts with your
framework of reference,
right?
With regards to this course,
it's a catastrophe.
With regards to my education,
it's an inconvenience with regards to my
career.
Wow.
It's tricky with regards to my life.
It's a nonentity,
right?
So you can switch the valence of,
uh,
an anomalous,
the valence on the anomalous piece of
information shift with frame of
reference.
That's a useful thing to know.
Okay.
So here's the idea.
If you're trying to get from here to
here and you have a plan but it doesn't
work,
right?
So within that larger frame of
reference,
you undergo a small descends into chaos
and you can come up with another plan.
But the chaos here,
this deals with some of the issues you
talked about.
If you me at one time too about the idea
that the chaos that was outside was also
inside.
Well that's how it works as far as I can
tell,
is that
the effect of valence of this particular
anomalous piece of information is
bounded by a larger story.
Okay?
So the thing is is it's a drag that you
get a b minus from the perspective of
the course.
But if you pop by the valence of that
anomaly is bounded by the fact that it's
really not going to hurt your education
goals that much and then it's not going
to affect your career at all.
So you have,
there's a domain,
there's a domain in which the anomalous
inflammation is actually valid and
there's a whole bunch of domains where
it isn't.
Now,
the problem is sometimes you encountered
anomalous piece of information
who's Valence is unbounded and blows
apart whole structures of stories.
So let's say this is a bit of a
different circumstance.
You're hovering on the edge of it except
for filigree.
For medical school,
it's like one more b minus your over
there.
So
you have a professor that everybody gets
along with except you can you get a d
minus for,
you know,
this is the end of medical school plus
there's this other residual mystery
leashes.
Why does everybody except you get along
with this person.
Maybe this is also something you've
noticed it on the classes.
It's like this particular piece of
anomalous information.
The domain is very unbounded,
right?
It blows the chorus.
It blows the educational table.
We'll say all you are going to
university for us to be a doctor.
That's it.
It's like the rest of it.
It was a means to an end and that's it.
You're not interested in biology.
Have no alternate.
That's right.
You don't have any other legs to stand
on.
That's right.
You've sacrificed your own interest
even,
which is a dangerous thing to do in
pursuit of this bound donated stability
that's gone well.
Then you have a piece of anomalous
information that's here.
It just below his whole sequences of
stories and you're depressed.
So the larger the area
inside each of these,
sorry,
these are the turtles all the way down
in the Roseville firmness and the
turtles go all the way down
anyways.
Anyways,
the broader the domain that the
anomalous information destroys,
the more of your life falls into pieces.
So that's why.
Well,
you can think of in terms of group
behavior,
to the degree that you and I share a
goal,
a threat to that story will unite us as
a group.
So let's say the Republicans hate
universities.
We both like universities.
Well,
therefore us,
for the purposes of that particular
event,
we constitute group.
But if the Republicans hate,
no,
let's say we go in the university
administration,
the Dean hates science,
but really likes the humanities and
you're in the humanities and the
sciences.
Well,
we're two different groups all of a
sudden.
That's right.
The anomalous information has a
different valence for us.
Our goals determined,
which are because we've identified with
a group or goals are going to determine
the information.
Also from cards,
the kids in group.
This is easier to understand
that there's all kinds of information
that complained you into despair that
don't seem to be directly related to any
plan of action.
Okay.
Next Diagram.
No,
this is how this is really good.
I just,
because there isn't any accident.
It's not a golden record.
That's right.
That's the,
that's the brief answer to that.
Look what this story does.
What
a story does literally is provide all
the events that you encounter with
determinants significance and they're
all construed.
The significance of any event is
construed with regards to its to its
perceived relationship to a goal.
Okay.
Say that it's the loss of your mother.
That doesn't seem to affect any story
that you can say you put your finger on.
Okay.
Well then the question is,
look,
this is tough.
This is a really tough issue.
I'm glad you brought it up because a lot
of the stories that we participate in
aren't explicit.
We can't state what they are.
You know,
for example,
I may indication you,
you can think about it.
If you think this is accurate,
you take something like the American
constitution.
Okay.
That's an explicit body of rules that
defines a state so that's a bounded,
don't make mistake but it's predicated
the first of that chapter he pointed out
in a Thomas Kuhn,
no current go down and sending them any
assistance internally.
Coherent and complete isn't necessarily
is predicated on preset positions that
can be proved for wind from within the
system.
Okay.
He's talking about this.
I think this infinite regressive systems
say,
well you can look at,
you play the geometries example except
the first five axioms.
Then you're in the story in a way you go
but you have to accept those axioms on
faith and I would say,
well those axioms are actually nasty in
another story and that story in term is
nested in another story in and so on and
so forth.
As far as you want to look.
The American constitution for example,
is predicated on these on natural
rights.
That's how I read it anyways,
is that,
which is an national rights are a brief
description,
some exquisite,
some implicit of what it means to be
human or what being human means.
It means lots of things.
It means that you're equal before God.
That would be the most fundamental
presupposition and that's a weird
question that deals with your request
and to some degree about the capability
of everybody to get to that highest
level of achievement.
While the constitution is predicated on
the notion that everyone has that
capacity,
everyone universally equally,
but everyone has the capacity to follow.
They go back,
but not necessarily to go to a certain
level.
That's true.
The level of the activity is individual
specific.
That's why you have individual
interests.
That's right.
That's what makes you individuals,
those things that appeal to you and your
domain of competence is unique,
but still the capacity to engage in this
process at some level,
we don't care what the problem is as
long as you're an to find with the
process you're identifying with the
process.
Anyways,
back to the idea of the constitution.
Well.
So it's predicated on these
presuppositions that I think have
religious,
they,
they're derived from religious
presuppositions,
especially the idea of equality of all
individuals.
Before we go on like that,
that idea is when its explicit form
that's 2000 years old.
Before that it sort of hung around.
The Egyptians thought that the higher
level of aristocrats who are perhaps
equivalent to the pharaoh in terms of
their potential for a motel,
but it wasn't made explicit till about
2000 years.
So it was implicit.
So it was the kind of story before it
was explicit.
It was in some other form.
So the question is,
we're not conscious of all her stories,
which is for me to say what I mean by
that is that although we have stories
some of the weekend,
we don't know they're there.
We can explain what they mean.
Some of our stories and the best we can
do is transmit them in images.
Some of them that we know even less,
well the best we can do is act out.
Okay.
Does that,
does that make any sense?
It's like we had religious stories.
They'd guarded their behavior.
They constituted the basis for our
unions into groups.
We had these stories,
but we didn't know what they meant.
So the story was it encoded in the form
of image and action and not coated in
the form of any sort of explicit
content.
You couldn't say what it meant.
So you're also saying,
hey,
we've got a nice story.
Tell him,
well,
that gas,
that's exactly the case.
At least that our stories,
it's a causal loop,
right?
Where does he tell the story?
Modifies the behavior,
but I would say to the degree that you
can draw a temporal influences,
the behavior precedes the description of
the behavior at least as often as the
description proceeds in the behavior it
needs.
You pointed out then like most most
western or just sort of have this
assumption that we construct it more
rules than we follow.
Nature said,
Donald,
we have more rules than we're embedded
in our behaviors.
We observe the,
we told stories about them.
Then we dissected the stories and we
came up with general principles.
Then once have you formulated the
general principles,
we turned around and said that the fact
that the general principles existed were
the reasons for the behavior wrong,
although north completely,
because once you can tell the story and
once you can make the most explicit,
that can change your behavior,
although it's not so easy.
Yeah.
You were saying that this case,
do you think that that would be stage?
No,
because usually what,
what what religious means is it means
dogma,
norm spirit,
right?
The reason that the church and the state
were separated but I think was quite
simple.
You have to make a distinction when you
talk about religious structures,
the explicit beliefs and the spirit that
moves the entire religion.
It's the same distinction that
Dostoyevsky was turning,
making the crab,
the dogmatic,
pardon?
The Catholic Church is tyrannical,
absolutely tyrannical.
All it is concerned with is the
position,
but then there's this other part.
This signified a Dostoevsky story by
Christ.
When those two cards come into contact
with them,
the dogmatic aspect attempts to kill the
creative aspect,
but in Dostoevsky story entirely,
let smoke the back door,
which is again,
that's why that's a brilliant story.
So the problem with the state and
religious because then the religion
becomes dogma and that's,
and I think part of the reason that the
church in the state are separated,
your part is to stop,
is another barrier stopping that from
happening.
But I would also say that the American
state,
it is religious as Protestant and it's
structured conflict.
Right.
You know what I said about organized
religion being designed to prevent you
from having a religious experience.
Right,
right.
Well,
yeah.
So that's,
that's where the dog with us and a good
thing too,
it's a good thing because
prior to the adolescent stage,
you don't want that sort of experience.
Like you don't want to expose your child
to the unknown if you want to expose
them in very measured doses,
under controlled conditions,
in a secure environment.
And then only when,
only when you can't do that anymore.
You say,
well,
you're on your own.
And the reason you say that is because
it's true.
It's like you know,
your mother can get dates for you.
That's just a condition of life,
eastern intention.
That's just reality.
So,
right.
We were talking about implicit stories.
So let's look at how these stories get
constructed.
This is an idea.
Yeah,
this is,
okay.
So here's your nasty story structure,
right?
All the way down.
There are stories.
Well,
how did the stories come about?
they come about empiricism.
Why put that in?
For reasons we can argue about that.
These are all different ways that we
figure out how to behave and sometimes
we figure out how to behave here and we
moved back here,
but sometimes we figured out how to
behave here and we move up here and each
of these levels in forms and alters all
the other levels
for those stories that are most profound
stories that we really understand
poorly.
What's happened.
Well,
if you put four people on an island and
they can't talk,
they're deaf and dumb,
they're going to organize their behavior
into a particular structure and that
structure takes into account fee.
Right now we're assuming that it's a a
healthy society.
People say,
well,
that's relativistic,
right?
There's lots of different sorts of
healthy societies.
I think that's a crock by the way,
but anyways,
they're going to,
they have a set number of problems to
solve and the problems are how does each
individual fulfill those tasks they have
to fulfill in order to live in the
presence of the other people who are
doing the same thing in a domain that's
bounded by whatever resources happened
to be there.
So there these people who can't talk
can't use language.
We're going to modify each other's
behavior by an exchange of information,
reinforcements,
positive reinforcement,
negative reinforcement,
punishments like we always modify each
other's behavior in every social
interaction by gesture and look and
attention and inattention,
they're going to construct a way of
being that has this structure.
None of them are going to be able to say
what it is say now take that analogy is
just an idea in imagination and extend
that to groups that can boast thousands
of people who'd been interacting over
hundreds of thousands of years.
It's all that social behavior from all
that social behavior emerges as a
pattern in so far as the culture is
successful,
we imitate behaviors that we see as
successful.
We play with the invitations and
ritualize the play and dramatize the
rituals and then we collect our
information about how to behave it
damages.
We formalize it into myths.
Once you have a religion established,
which is a codify description of
acceptable behavioral patterns,
you can start drawing general rules from
it.
Then you can start criticizing so forth
and so on.
Each emergent level of abstraction
alters the function of all the previous
levels
and that's how we construct our stories.
Now the danger of course is that
having abstract and up the story,
they part of the story,
you can criticize it and destroy it
without even understanding what it was.
The dealer then you were destroyed.
We knocks and I think that's what we've
done.
Once we go up to this level,
all of these levels we were storing to
behavior and analyze it.
We developed a scientific methodology
and said,
that's not what the universe is like.
Bang everyone.
All the stories.
Well,
it's just the stories philosophy.
Well because,
okay,
well the bridge from philosophy
rationalities isn't too too,
it doesn't seem to be qualitatively
different.
I mean science was originally called,
right,
but look what are all I would say here.
Is that up to this point,
right?
Yes.
That's why I said I didn't know if I
should put this in.
It is confused.
Absolutely.
Then that's probably the problem with
this particular diagram.
Something happened here.
What happened here was that from here to
here when we said knowledge of the
world,
what we meant was knowledge of world
pots,
knowledge of how to behave.
When we got to hear what we said was
that the world was a place where fact
that the world was a place of facts and
we saw that the world of facts wasn't
constructed.
The way the world that you act in was
constructed in our images,
which is to say there isn't a garden
handling devil man.
Isn't that the center of the university?
From a factual perspective and all
these,
and from the empirical perspective,
it seems very unlikely that the world
was created in seven days and so on and
so forth.
And it looks like there was evolution
and that really played havoc with this
whole sequence of stories.
The problem was these stories were about
the world as a place to APP and not
about the world as a collection of
facts.
So made a category error here,
I think,
and undermined our belief in our
accumulated how old shoe without ever
understanding explicitly.
So
that maybe shouldn't be there,
but it does come at the end of the
process of abstraction,
I think from an historic perspective.
So does that help
you still have a residual concern
now?
I think the enthusiasm that you have,
there's empiricism criticism that that
everyone else thinks is empiricism.
Empiricism that that you would like us
to attain.
No,
sorry.
you shouldn't get that complicated with
this.
I mean I just put down,
I just put that here because it looked
to me like it was at the end of the
historical chain of development.
But it's qualitatively different in some
ways than these things.
Okay.
This represents a store like,
well part,
it's complicated because you shouldn't
have stories.
But I would say yes but,
but it's not,
it's not so simple because we had
religion at only afterwards.
No,
no,
that's the problem.
That's why it's,
no,
no I didn't.
There should be arrows back and forth
all the way off but okay,
so because that's what I said,
every time a new level emerges,
it modifies all the previous levels and
all the levels that are in front of it.
So you get,
you get this Lupo cutting a multi
dimensional causal loop of phenomenon.
But it does also seem to be a certain
amount of historicity to it.
Which is to say that rational philosophy
or even philosophy say that at least as
an emergent property,
maybe of complex language you use,
it's only been around for 5,000 years
possibly.
So it seems,
it's hard to say.
Do is what pre empirical Sharman
engaging comparable to philosophy?
Well,
I don't know either and there's a lot of
arguments about this.
I'm not thinking of this as a simple
historical progression,
but there's a historical aspect to it I
think.
Whereas here it is a qualitative,
um,
la,
it's a hierarchy because it seems like
in is a point at which you can,
you can talk,
you can start experimenting with not
only objects and facts,
but also with,
with myths.
And you can start talking about
religions in the,
in an objective manner I guess,
which is what you want to be able to do
with what you're teaching.
Well,
that's possible.
So,
but your philosophy
is,
is thinking about these ideas of
behavior.
Empiricism is actually testing out these
ideas and behavior and subject to when
you have a philosophy that some of what
Moses,
a formulaic way,
I mean it's clear a lot of play back and
forth.
I shouldn't have,
I shouldn't have put this in here
because when you've used [inaudible]
instead of what it is in terms of what
it does to the things that came before
it.
That's true.
That's the match space of food.
The reason that it's in there is because
it does.
That's a very good point.
It has an effect on because each of
these emergent abilities has an effect
on everything that goes before the new
imperialism has,
has uh,
has a dramatic effect on our,
on our ability to believe.
The stories that were constructed at
this point is with regards to the
historicity of it.
It is the case that we organized our
behavior before we understood how we
did.
So our,
our capacity here in here seems to be
filing genetically more ancient than our
task is farther on down the line.
They also seem to be more linguistically
depending on as you move down the chain,
it's right.
You get a lot of inventory of behavior
and invitation with primates a lot and
they can move a lot of information
around that way.
Lord,
Cultural Information and certainly it's
the case that much of the information
that we get from each other,
hookers it down a level and I think
that's fine.
Genetically more ancient Merlin.
Donald,
you're never heard of the dorm.
He was here for a while.
I was a visiting scholar.
You gave a quote a couple of years back.
He wrote a whole book on about a third
of the book is called the evolution of
the motor mind on the role of imitation.
My nieces,
he calls it his culture constructing
role.
These are place that communicating
information about behaviors about,
yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
Okay.
That's what they're what?
Not only that their ways of constructing
stories like Elliot,
he points out,
for example,
in the Polynesians go fishing with a
polynesian goes fishing and feminine are
Pretty Empirical Polynesian.
He adopts the guys of the ancestral hero
who first fish for the Polynesians.
Now Eliana has pointed out that if you
go back three generations in pretty
literate cultures,
all the historical events that occurred
before that are sort of telescope into
the time that existed before the present
time and all they remember is the things
that they should remember,
which is how to act and how to act.
Which in this case is how to fish,
is to imitate the ritual model
efficient,
which is all the Polynesians collection
of successful behaviors.
About how to catch fish that had been
stored and transmitted down the
generations using this sort of process.
They imitate,
say,
well,
maybe they are.
You can imagine the Polynesian children
playing out the fishing routine.
It's a ritual as well.
Who knows?
And that culture,
maybe it's also something that's
dramatic.
I don't know.
So I think more more than a historical
chain.
This is a chain of obstruction and it
increases as you go down,
and I think it's
roughly analogous to this behavioral
information moves from here to here to
here.
First we are,
then we make images of reduction.
Then we tell stories about the end of
this,
of the action.
Then we use words to describe the images
of the action that is a store.
So when I read your Shakespeare in play,
I'm using words to activate memories in
your imagination of behavioral patterns
and that's where the inflammation is.
It's not in the words.
That's why
people have said that Shakespeare knew
everything.
That for ideas for example.
That's how I tried to think it explicit.
Shakespearian still implicit still.
I would say most of your information
scale here and this system is just
killing me.
That's what you do with the kids too.
Anyways,
the point of all of this was to kind of
describe our stories be constructed and
you'd asked the questions wrong stories
that are implicit to me.
You're saying anomalous event,
old curves and you say,
well frank the mother and uh,
you can't say what story disrupt.
Well,
I would say that's in large part because
as you move out to larger and larger
scale structures of stories,
in a sense you moved back in a sense you
move backwards in time.
God,
well,
yeah,
because the,
the stories get more and more archaic
and less and less explicit.
So I,
you could ask the average undergraduate
what are the presuppositions of the
American constitution and they might be
able to list off the rights and then you
say,
well,
what's outside of that?
Well,
the English Libertarian tradition,
English new contribution.
Okay.
That's philosophy.
That's outside of that.
Well then then you might get the answer.
Well,
it's the Judeo Christian culture in the
western tradition.
Okay.
Things are starting to get pretty vague
at that point,
which is to say that the outer levels
are still mostly implicit.
And then the question is what does
implicit me?
And I would say,
well what it means is that the
information there is still lodged mostly
in image and in coded in behavior,
but not explicit.
So here's another example.
There's a group of two year olds,
pre verbal,
two year olds,
because I grew up for two year olds.
They're all acting in a very complex
manner.
And you go in there and you study,
you're trying to derive rules like
piaget for their behavior.
It lists all these rules,
say the children are behaving according
to those worlds,
which is wrong.
They don't know the rules.
They can't say that.
Now if you say they're behaving good
rules,
what you're saying is that there are
rules that can,
that can be followed but not stated.
The polls described.
Yeah,
but okay,
okay,
fair enough.
And I would say,
well that's what we're doing to the
rules described our rules and describe
our behavior,
but the behavior precedes the rules.
So in what form are the rules?
If they're not explicit,
like the children are acting out
patterns that you could use words to
describe as rules,
where are the patterns?
What are they,
where are they?
Well,
they're certainly in the children's
behavior,
so I would say they're coded into
procedural memory.
How do we get there?
The children,
the children watched their parents act
and imitating and played with the
invitation plus in their social
intercourse,
not only with their parents but with
their parents.
Their behavior is constantly being
modified by the exchange of reinforcers.
So that constructs a pattern which you
can use rules to described.
You can use words to describe where you
can tell a story about the child's
behavior,
which is what you very [inaudible],
what he would spend all day studying
kids and he went home.
You'd said,
I saw the cutest thing today.
Then you tell the story and that would
be a way of getting the information
about this behavior out.
A few levels of abstraction you can
codify it to,
I'd say you're engaged in this process,
so
as you go out levels of analysis,
you go back in time.
That's one way of looking at it.
You also moved from the explicit to the
implicit increasing.
So when you say an anomalous event
occurs and I can identify the story,
it affects,
I would say,
well,
it's having an impact out of story level
of it's not explicit.
Absolutely.
It's unconscious.
It's coated in these images.
It's coded in the myths.
We're not aware of just telling stories
and we're acting it out.
We're,
we're acting it out.
But look,
if if,
let's say you're severely
psychopathological and you go in,
you see a psychologist and you say,
this is my ideal future,
but this is always what keeps happening.
Well,
I would say there's no isomorphism
between what's happening here and what's
being stated here,
which is to say the person's actions act
of a story that the person does not know
explicitly,
which is why union said you should know
the myth that you're lending to me if
outbreaks here and here and Mcclellan
has noted the same sort of thing.
I think it's something that is very much
analogous.
He says that that's why he looks at the
thematic apperception test your explicit
statements about who you are and what
you want.
Do not match your episode with
representations and if you want to
predict behavior,
this is to point anyways.
You look here,
not here.
So when he's looking for things like
need for achievement,
which I think is really interesting
cause that's Carol and long
cultures that have a lot of need for
achievement,
like themes in their children's stories
have higher socioeconomic status and
that's because those are here in this,
the coding here,
people act them out there,
talk to the kids.
It's all unconscious.
Then the question is what is unconscious
mean?
This is what it means.
It's coated in behavior or it's an
image.
It's not yet explicit.
So this is also a way of kind of trying
to address the idea of the collective
unconscious in a more
differentiated manner.
See what it might be.
Sorry,
but back to my mother.
Yes.
Every,
anything owe my entire life.
Takes all the energy out of your options
in notes,
listen way,
I can't tie it in.
And did you go there?
There was nothing that I was going to do
for that I can't do no right or that I
shouldn't do.
Now in school serves a purpose
just date,
which implicitly includes your one goal
as a state.
Well,
it also,
it also might,
mortality is a good,
a good issue because the problem with
with the,
the dramatic demonstration of mortality
is that it's the form of,
it's a form of anomalous information
that can Noriko your highest levels of
stories that I heard.
There is severe repercussions because
I'm faced with my own mortality.
I have no,
I would say that this is more and more,
more particularly the severe
repercussions are because the story that
you've been telling yourself no longer
maintains its validity in the light of
an event.
That's not dramatic because I would say
what?
That's an indication that the story
you've been telling yourself does not
include the fact of mortality as a
constituent element and is therefore
vulnerable to bad as an intrusive event,
which is to say you don't have a story
that makes sense of mortality and most
of the Times
shall we go with go ahead.
Okay.
I was just going to say also I think a
mother is a culture of other is the guy
for how to behave in the face of the
night.
That's certainly the case officer.
Well,
that way if you lose a mother,
you've really lost.
You've lost your means of knowing how to
behave right in the face of anomalous
information.
No,
that's the last of the process because
you can't go back to your mother and
find out how to deal with new
information here.
Here's an example.
That's a very good point.
That's much simpler than the way I was.
I was going about it.
Agoraphobic women often experience a
dramatic loss in the pre developmental
period of their pathology and
agoraphobic people,
I think are people whose stories that
collapse completely for
fear of,
it's basically fear of leaving any place
that's viewed as secure.
So when you used to be called fear of
open spaces,
but it's more like it's fear of being
away from security,
fear to Ventura,
fear of being away from hospitals or
doctors or actually figures of authority
is really what it boils down to.
So you're a 45 or 50 year old woman,
your husband dies,
your developmental history is,
you're a dependent child.
You married at the age of 17 you relied
on your husband to make his decisions
and he's divorced.
It's like what's happened is your
culture has disappeared because your
mode of adaptation was normally what
does my husband,
so it's recourse to authority.
So there's a little authoritarian drama
going on in your family and the tyrant
and became just die a your own thorough
information.
Specific goals
under what circumstances?
Either.
Yeah,
either.
It's a huge,
yeah.
So either it's a huge impact because
there are some
super story implicit in which having
your mother is a big part.
Right.
Realize this,
find that story somewhere or you've lost
your mode of adaptation,
which is that's another cost,
which is the process.
Your ability now to take Allen's
information guide and then reintegrate.
You feel you've lost that,
right?
That kind of grant.
That is literally the case with
children.
Right.
If they lose it,
their parents,
it's like because they're motivated.
The childhood mode of adaptation is
authoritarian more or less.
It's like if something anomalous
happens,
I asked mom and dad and they tell me
what to do,
so when you lose a parent at that age,
you literally do use,
do lose your process.
It's an authoritarian process,
but it's necessarily most of them to
kids do some exploratory.
Yeah,
well I was just speaking roughly
politically.
It's just rich.
It's like there are different modes of
adaptation.
Three of them actually I think one is
recourse to authority.
One is decadence,
he just give up.
The other is the pattern that we're
trying to outline and society's waiver
between the first two because sometimes
the solution is authoritarianism.
There's too many.
Like there's,
there's too many refugees,
let's close the borders and enforce
uniformity.
Or our culture is threatened by forces
that we can,
we can't tolerate,
well we'll just give up the parish.
And I think that's what happened.
[inaudible] enrollments for example.
It's like when they were fighting over
the gun,
they had an army to do this perfectly
sufficient to repel the invading forces
being too many gods and died of
indigestion.
So,
and then so then the Dallas would say,
well if your culture is out of whack,
it's because there's too much chaos,
furthers,
too much order.
It was too much.
He ended or there's too much.
You have to put the balance back yet.
And then the proper mode of adaptations
walking down the line.
And then that's another example of what
we're trying to lay out.
Can I just say something maybe coming on
this other thing.
I mean it seems to me that what,
what this is to say this whole picture
to put quite simply is that we are
creatures of habit and your story,
which is the domain of the known
includes well is really everything and
that is experience which includes all of
your history and your mother is one of
the most fundamental constituents of
your entire history.
So even if it doesn't have anything to
do specifically with any of your higher
level goals,
it's still blowing holes in your,
in your story,
which disregulates your some of your
stories for sure.
But I mean the stories I was going home
for Christmas to visit her mother for
example,
is pretty much that little thing that's
there.
The larger,
the more
trauma it's going to cost when it's gone
because the more you're,
the more you count on it,
right?
The morning depends on absolutely.
And that sees because the question we're
trying to answer is here is what can you
depend on when there isn't anything to
depend on?
Right.
It's like if you lose a little of the
coastline,
it's not so surprising,
but if something drops out of the
middle,
it's very peculiar.
Kind of reminds me of that.
It seems to me girls do tend to go from
here to here without descending to this
level.
Therefore,
the
more of an influence on the adolescent
female.
Well,
I've never really,
I've never really thought about,
I never considered the possibility of
sex differences in this process.
And I'm sure that there are sex
differences.
Well,
I'm not even sure what the main,
so
you say,
you said there are three months,
what do you call
that was used term for Nietzsche called
to power,
which I think was basically what he was
after.
I don't know,
call it the camel.
The child.
Right,
right,
right.
So,
um,
I don't know what you'd call
the third way is,
I mean there's descriptive terms of all
sorts of business to be used to describe
it.
It's also,
you know,
you see books alluded to this at the
time,
all the time,
like the razors edge by Somerset Mall.
That's it.
That's another image of this path
because it's balanced between to balance
between chaos and order basically to
raise money is literally amazing.
Sandwich summer stuff.
Mom's book is about something that
you've discovered that I go into.
The East is the hero culture.
So what,
what?
Well,
I wanted to show you the notion of these
nested stories and also the idea that
anomalous inflammation can occur within
any bounded domain and range and that's
something that's very interesting.
George Kelly said
it's also the case that anomalous
information range of effect and there is
a,
there are occasions where you encounter
a piece of anonymous information.
It might take decades to recuts have off
on all the levels of analysis that it's
actually a challenge because you have to
figure it out.
I just think something like,
let's take your example again.
If a parent dies,
there are implications for that at all
sorts of different levels of analysis.
Some of which might not become evidence
for for years told them this story.
I was thinking about this more
particular both niches,
notion of who definitely gone every time
one of these levels of analysis
collapses and that's up.
Danny definitely gone so to speak.
The God that rules,
no,
the ancient Romans,
they used to think that every different
room that had it go off and I guess in a
sense what they were alluding to was the
fact that you have different patterns of
goal directed activity in every specific
contexts and they should be doing,
and I read you that that India met the
other day about endless cycles of
embedded creation and destruction and
that's what these,
each of these stories goes through this
process of descent in reconstruction at
every different level of analysis when
you encounter something really anomalous
that Lowe's who knows how many new
story.
That's the thing.
I guess the only way to think about that
as in terms of the contact of cultures
that had appeared before the isolated.
So they did their whole developmental
history has been separate.
Then they come together and some
terrible catastrophe usually.
Well,
it's a catastrophe or to me,
this opportunity
ends on the circumstances
with regards to automation for social
confidence is
the thing that people are motivated to
avoid.
Above all,
the outside thing are involuntary high
level challenges to stories,
so they're were very much motivated to
eliminate or ignore or repress or
otherwise
obliterate any evidence that suggests
that are higher level structures about
or insufficient because when we lose
those,
we lose everything.
That's nested loop.
That's the
anomaly.
An anomaly that's relevant at one level
tends to demolish all the levels that
are inside of all those levels inside of
dependent on that store.
Next class we're going to talk about
some of them.
We're going to talk about some of the
ways that anomalous information
manifests itself and the basic,
the easiest way to conceptualize that is
that anomaly can occur at any of these
levels of analysis,
so the mere presence of someone who
behaves differently,
for example,
can constitute a challenge to the
integrity of your stories.
The stories that someone tells us that
the Ford,
that's another example of that.
We'll be here.
Alternative miss can wreak havoc on your
culture.
Can have.
Certainly the case when you think about
that in terms of the clash of religions,
new ideas can blow your stories.
And all of this information comes in all
of those guys as and their stories about
their stories,
about his appearance,
each of those guys.
So we're going to talk a little bit
about how anomalous information
manifests itself and then the core
switches into the last half,
which is much more focused on the movie.
So we have time
well,
but at the same time there are
individual differences.
I mean you've ever,
every individual's episodic and
procedural memories.
Yeah.
Well I think,
I mean I think,
I think it's
gender roles and the West are becoming
more and more for many cultures.
There's a strict distinction between the
sexes.
There were native native American
cultures where the men and the women
spoke different languages.
So it depends on the culture,
but it certainly,
there are many cultures where,
where women live that that's,
that's the case where we're women had a
domain of activity that was their sacred
domain and the same with the men.
And there was no cross talk to speak of
women to a
traditional domains of women have been
closed cloth making pottery and
agriculture three nontrivial domains.
Yes,
yes,
absolutely.
Of course.
Yeah.
I was thinking more specifically
cultural issues.
So yeah.
And then I would say,
well yes,
the procedural memories.
Well just to a certain agreement.
This is there in terms of their habits.
Richard Cory story pretty different.
Well,
like I said,
this is something that I have agreed
work though cause I don't know,
a lot of the feminine images in
mythology seem to me to be
representations of the unknown rather
than representations of the individual.
And like Newman would say,
well the feminine feminine consciousness
construed as the hero is masculine.
Symbolically it doesn't,
it has nothing to do with gender except
I suppose perhaps that
the aztecs temps for the Aztecs,
a woman who died in childbirth went to
the same heaven.
The warriors when two if they were
killed in battle.
Well,
so I would say even there and that's,
that's pretty much good.
Even the bylaws,
the most biological aspect of a woman's
role was construed as heroic in that in
that particular case.
So as as equivalent to two more.
What about the idea that the myths that
are part of our culture,
it's Disney or something would you
showed us how to bless her prince
charming figure who identifies with the
hero and it goes out and conquers this
dragon whatever for the principals or
rescues the princess and so that people
will identify along gender lines.
Men are taught to identify,
her boys are taught to identify with the
friends and to what extent women are
taught to identify with the sort of the
Barbie doll with the princess or the the
sort of,
well this is another issue.
It's like I think one of the reasons
that the fairy tales tend to port.
This isn't nice.
Nice idea.
In light in the Aztec notion that fairy
tales tend to portray,
we even say us dependent.
So for someone to rescue them.
Well,
I would say the reason for that is
because this is my own personal
interpretation,
is the in more traditional cultures,
which I would just say,
or cultures that don't have access to
reliable birth control,
women aren't necessarily put into a
dependent position by the biology and
the,
and the notion of heroism that those
tails sort of portray is voluntary
acceptance of that rule and voluntary
acceptance of the necessity for a
protracted period of dependence.
And it's reasonable to construe that as
a form of hero is.
So that's why the Aztecs had this
particular attitude.
Biology,
Freud,
biology is destiny.
Well,
that's true and not true.
It's not so much destiny when you have
the birth control pill,
but without it,
there's a big chunk of destiny there.
So,
and it's voluntarily facing the things
that have to be faced that constitutes
Hiro is so that,
I don't know how that applies to our age
in an age of birth control.
Still the matter of taught to be here at
the women I've talked to.
Well,
first of all,
there hasn't been enough time for our
stories to the change.
And second,
in many ways things haven't changed.
Like if you,
if you have a baby,
there's a year.
It depends.
You can do with lots of ways you can,
you can put the baby in daycare.
Well that's a solution of a trump.
All that means is that the dependency
stage is transferred to someone else.
It's still there.
It's just be moved usually down the
socioeconomic ladder.
But anyways,
if you don't choose that you have a one
year period where there's something
that's absolutely dependent on you to
the degree that it would be really
useful for you to be able to be
dependent on someone else.
So to the degree that child rearing
still is a feminine role and I think
it's going to be a long time before that
that changes.
If it ever changes,
who knows what will happen.
The notion of voluntary dependency still
has an aspect of truth.
That's how I look at it.
And it's dangerous.
Like there's lots of people who've
wanted to rewrite fairy tales.
No,
because they have sexist things.
But Shelly pointed out something
interesting in her last essay.
Tell you the three little pigs,
you know,
they keep building houses and you get
stronger and stronger.
The wolf closed them down,
but finally they build a stone house or
a brick house and the wolf climate
through the chimney,
but he falls into a bowl of water and
then the pigs eat,
cook,
and eat him.
Well,
she always pointed out that in the
sanitized versions,
Wolf just pops down the fire decisions
his tail,
and he goes back up through the chimney
and he gets away.
She meant,
she pointed out,
well,
the fact of having constructive this
fortress in the proper manner allowed
enough of the external unknown,
symbolized by the wolf to enter.
We can be prepared and to simulate it.
Now you say,
oh,
this is a violent story.
The poor wolf.
Well,
it's like you're thinking here about
something that's all encoded here.
So you mess around with,
you say,
well,
it'd be much nicer if the wolf gone
away.
All right,
fine.
But there's no story that we just like
the reason you built the stone house,
it's so that you can cook any the wolf.
Well you lose the graphic imagery,
you lose the story.
And that's the problem with messing
about with traditional tales.
I mean I can understand why people want
to do it and there's lots of traditions
perhaps than artists,
so beneficial.
But
it might be good to understand that
before they are trans transformed.
The other thing is is that we do not
have an answer to the question.
What constitutes a valid feminine idea?
Um,
well just about the feminine part of the
wanting to say.
It seems to me that what the feminine,
the Feminine
counterpart of exploratory behavior is
endurance of the rather than exploration
feed meals through myth are taught to
endure.
Not necessarily dependency I don't
think,
but just just to endure it,
to sit there and write it out.
And um,
it seems to me that that in fairy tales,
Gannon mythology,
that's what the four females have to do.
They don't get to actively explore the
and just endure it.
And that's how they,
we come here because the thing is if you
have a problem,
there's two things you can do about it.
You can either change how you're
accurate.
Right.
I do think it's the case among human
beings in general
are view down is both more necessary.
I'm more expendable,
both at the same time.
So I met Andrew sent off to war foods,
got a lot of useless side less than men
hanging road.
Well,
that's a good thing for them to do and
that's basically how society worked.
Boys,
all boys fight wars,
they're expendable.
The thing about something that's
expendable is then it can also be
something that's very creative because
exploration is dangerous and if you lose
a few adolescent males while they're off
exploring around,
well,
okay,
you know,
tough luck.
Whereas women,
well you to have them around.
Well that's all that goes to my question
that I asked you yesterday.
Can there be too many heroes?
It seems to me there's only a certain
amount of creativity that any society
can endure at a given time.
If you've got everybody out there trying
to bring the end.
That's why I mentioned today that there
are three patterns.
Adaptation.
There is recourse to authority.
That's the authoritarian.
There's whatever we're talking about and
there's decadence and decadence occurs
when under the guise of constant
creative behavior,
everything he's on the fine,
but it's the case.
Your old man says when you explore,
you bring your culture along with you
and that because you're right,
you're absolutely right.
I mean constant heretical activity.
You mean the Catholic church in middle
ages burned heretics.
So why was that?
Well,
because you couldn't say there was that
anytime and feeling you're going to give
them any,
we'll touch you.
There's like 250 religious visionaries
wandering around.
Well,
they followed them to establish a
religion.
Well instantly you have 250 countries
all fighting with one another.
The Catholics,
they didn't know and we still don't
know.
How do you mediate between competing
moral claims knows suppressant.
Why?
Cause you need to order.
Well,
Darren was their attitude and it's
understandable and you saying well the
inquisition and so on.
Yeah.
Well,
no kidding.
It's a terrible thing.
I'm not saying it's not a terrible thing
to bunch of order is a catastrophe and
so was too much chaos come too much.
Cannabis is generated by careless,
creative back,
careless activity that runs under the
guise of hero,
but that's why they miss safe.
You're going to be here and you master
the culture first before you and you're
buying it because otherwise he might do
something careless that you think is
creative that blows everything is like a
minor example is the modification of
that 30 day.
So keeping them being,
telling them I'm fairy tale for God only
knows how long and someone comes along
and chops the ending off.
It's like,
oh,
this isn't violent.
That isn't even at the point.
That's careless.
The SEC,
so not is definitely a danger.
When I said the Romans died,
it digest it.
That's not a joke.
It's like they expanded like math
collected all these gods.
It's like their morality was,
was was decimated.
They didn't know how to,
I'm getting more so in nature.
That's a neat unity.
That's the morning of European is full
been in cultures.
So that's why we're at war with
ourselves
historically and cultural constructions
of gender or
simultaneously like,
um,
the mother or like the source of all
things and yet the unknown.
Right.
So it's interesting to look at the woman
and say,
you know,
how she sees herself rough,
how she says your story because yes,
she had one,
one,
one or scratch.
She is the source of all things.
And the other respect she has dean.
And you can look like culturally,
like when you talked about the
inquisition,
like at that time,
the woman,
we're all being witches because,
um,
basically they were trying to uphold the
tradition.
Um,
so they were all good,
just,
you know,
doing these crazy rituals and they were
the threat.
They are the enemy.
They were the know.
Whereas like,
um,
which is something we'll start rolling
through our history.
The woman is,
which can cure danger,
you know,
and you know,
yeah.
Well that's the split.
The split of the archetype is the
archetype of the unknown is feminine and
Feminine Femininity has two positive and
negative and positive.
The medieval culture that was sort of
wrapped up in symbolism around the
Virgin Mary and the other counselors
sort of more occupied this territory of
the witch.
So is he going to do,
so I'm just reiterating your point.
You that applies to fit females is very
complicated because you have all these
different aspects.
The embodiment of the unknown plus the
capacity for her rote behavior be more
than than,
than,
than creative and
exploratory behavior.
And those two things are hard to me.
There are
two stories that are very different on
the woman tells her story,
the story that she's trying new things
and then she's a witch and she has to
integrate that because you have to
understand yourself or stories you,
when women were separated during that
stretch,
nope,
they had to incorporate that into who
they were.
You know,
they were danger that.
So there's two different stories and I
think that's ultimately left the store
of a problem,
understanding who you are,
the middle also,
all three,
all three pieces of the entire world,
both,
both you and kill you.
Right.
So if that's true,
that's true.
That's true.
Well,
I don't like,
I don't know how true that is.
I suspect that,
I doubt that it's true because,
well,
here's an example.
If you want to predict the education
status of a child,
the best predictors,
mother's level of education,
farthest of the two parents,
father's level of education does not
correlate well.
It correlates with the mother's level of
education.
So that's true,
but it does,
doesn't,
is not anywhere near as good as good a
predictor for the child's development in
his mother's lap.
So,
and I think it's reasonable to say that
in large part,
women are the primary socialization
agents.
At least they have been historically for
the first two years,
three years,
maybe even longer than that.
So I don't,
I don't.
Plus I also don't think that women's
role in history has been nearly as
subordinate.
And as people generally claim,
it depends on your,
on your standard for defining
subordination.
I'm not saying that there's,
there were that at every level of
analysis,
functionally quality range.
Cause that's not true.
But I also think that women and men,
men doesn't impact on the course of
giving them,
develop
their contributions.
I don't think,
I don't really think that we might have
been session male structure.
You are just like that.
The fact,
for example,
their men are all the sacrifice,
but nor is one example of that.
That tends to be overlooked in peaceful
times.
Well
sacrifice.
How
well fairly fair enough.
I mean there are problems in gender
relationships and an adaptation
everywhere in peaceful times.
Maybe men have the upper hand,
but more
the situation,
at least historically these movers
directly voted to take
it was through the perspective of mail,
written history,
tradition,
and
sort of
develop the idea of freedom because
they're the ones that had
kind of freedom.
I think women have been powerful.
Yeah,
so I agree with you,
but I think they've been written into
history from the male perspective and
that could be us or women have had a
huge,
their story has been written by now.
Stories are written by people who have
leisure.
That's right.
Our primary child care,
especially if that also shortens your
lifespan.
Women's influence,
maybe large and implicit in what the
stories and the items are.
All exquisite needs.
You said that one of the reasons western
culture was so powerful was because his
philosophy was written by bachelors.
Good observation,
observation.
But it does take leisure.
Leisure.
We started the course.
Yeah.
Well one of the things I was trying to
do at the beginning of the class was to
out how an explicit story puts 4
million,
can fund your mind.
A whole sequence of implicit stories.
That's really the notion behind the
conflict between
miracle stories.
Really explicit.
You can grasp
once you accepted.
I've been thinking about
why it is,
I'm a singer and I see a lot of a lot of
homosexuals in the art scene and stuff
like that.
And I was wondering why,
you know,
why is it that they tend to,
a lot of them tend to go into the arts
and,
and are very successful at it.
And I was thinking that maybe because
they are forced to a lot of times to um,
to partake in a group that they aren't
necessarily a part of our,
at least for us in that heterosexuality
is adolescence.
And then have to have to fight out of
that had to have a really huge internal
struggle if they ever do make it out of
it.
Um,
and then at that point they are able to
add,
they're able to add more to the group
through things like our creative
processes,
sorry,
builds up creative ability or that they
advanced at an earlier age because they
have this,
you know,
the saying that they want,
and this is by the way,
this enormous anomalous information I
thought about sometimes in terms of the
necessity for people who are homosexual
to integrate different gender roles.
And so I thought they could serve the
people in that position because the fact
that homosexuality is very peculiar from
an evolutionary point of view,
it's hard to account for its existence
from the blue.
And I thought,
well maybe we need to do a particular
cultural intermediary between the sexes
possibility or,
or in between the mental logic in the
meetings with the masculine and
feminine,
you have another hypothesis.
You know,
sometimes one of the best niches if
doesn't kill you,
makes you stronger.
Sometimes best trade you can have really
cool because if you overcome it well,
then you've got something.
Although you might die.
Just
the downside.
Okay,
so next week we talked about,
no two weeks.